- Un oléoduc de 2000 km
en pleine construction.
Une infrastructure monstre pour
transporter l'or noir du Niger.
C'est que les États africains
clament leur droit au
développement just
équitable. Et pour se faire,
ils misent sur leurs énergies
fossiles.
- Cet t t t a une importance
capitale pour nos trois pays.
- Comme les pays développés
ont eu la chance de le faire.
Une contradiction totale
avec le discours ambiant
dans les corridors de la COP 27.
À la conférence, cet écologiste
nigérien est en mission :
convaincre les pays
développés de payer leur juste
part aux pays en développement
pour qu'ils puissent envisager
eux aussi une transition verte.
Sans quoi il craint que
le secteur pétrolier n'explose
sur son continent.
- On n'est pas sorti du sous-
développement et pour en
sortir, on ne peut pas faire
du développement sans l'énergie
et cette énergie aujourd'hui,
pour nous, c'est le pétrole.
- Pour déplos s s s énergies
vertes, il faut : technologies
et moyens financiers.
Deux choses que les pays en
développement ont très peu,
faute de transfert financiers
adéqeseseses plus grands
pollueurs du monde.
Que faire?
- Est-ce que le Niger va
croiser les bras pour regarder
sa population périr, pour
regarder ses animaux périr,
pour regarder son environnementt
une alternative.
- Un point de vue que partage
cet ace e e e climatique
togolais.
SENA ALOUKA, Jeunes volontaires
pour l'environnement
- Est-ceeseseses pays du sud
ont également le droit de
pouvoir se développer en
utilisant, en exploitant
intelligemment, rationnellement
leurs ressources? Et que vous
00000000 millions d'Africains
qui cuisinent encore aujourd'hui
avec du bois de feu. Dans mon
pays le Togo, la cuisine mal
faite tue 5000 personnes par an.
C'est beaucoup plus que
le sida et le palu réunis.
- Sena Alouka prône une
approche rationnelle envers
l'exploitation des ressources
pétrolière. Il met même en garde
contre les possibles dérapages.
- À cette COP, on a vu l'Union
européenne presque signer
un contrat avec l'Égypte
g g g gaz. Et ça continue.
L'Allemagne est allée vers
le Sénégal, etc. On voit
quand même qu'il y a un appétits
africaines. Est-ce qu'on va
bâtir la transition énergétique
dans le nord sur les ressources
du sud?
- Selon un rapport publié
pendant la COP, des projets
d'exploration et d'exploitation
de ressources fossiles sont
en cours dans 48 des 54 pays
africains. Deux tiers de
ces projets sont financés
par des multinationales
étrangères et sont destinés
à l'exportation. Besoins
africains ou non, beaucoup
pensent que ses ressources
sortiront de terre.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, Charm el-Cheikh